Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. Today we'll be deep diving into
Twitter. Uh I didn't really have too
much time last week to get it done, so
we're going to try it out now. Uh would
not recommend doing Twitter deep dives.
The last time I did one, the SWAT team
showed up at my house. So I am naively
doing it again. Hopefully it goes a
little bit better this time. Let's get
into it. To start off this video, let's
do a very quick recap of last video. If
any of this is unclear to you, I'd
recommend watching that one in full.
Let's go through our final design by
implementing our three main APIs.
Creating a tweet, following a user, and
fetching a newsfeed. First, let's create
a post. Then, let's follow a user. For
our newsfeed API, we need to support a
bunch of types of fast reads. The first
requires maintaining an index to figure
out a user's followers. Next, we need to
be able to quickly determine which users
are popular. This comes in handy to
avoid fanning out popular tweets and
figuring out which tweets we should load
from the post DB.
Now we can listen to change data capture
from our post database in order to fan
out posts to a tweet author's followers.
We'll only do so for posts from
unpopular authors. When fetching a feed,
we'll first begin by reading from the
feed database. In parallel, we'll figure
out which popular users this user
follows by comparing who they follow
with the set of popular users. We'll
fetch posts from this list of popular
users. Now, taking advantage of our post
look aside cache where possible. In this
section, I want to focus on three main
things. The first is going to be
figuring out a better way to compute our
popular users. The next is going to be
about how we can speed up post rights as
much as possible. Finally, let's talk
about whether we really need this whole
complicated fanout architecture in the
first place. Recall that to simplify
figuring out which one of our users are
popular, we run a scheduled batch job to
count the followers from each user. We
then populate a cache in order to list
out all of their user IDs. If you think
about it, this is actually pretty
wasteful. Generally speaking, there are
probably only a couple of people per day
that pass the threshold of 10,000
followers. Yet, we're deliberately
rescanning the entire database and
putting a bunch of load on it. Instead,
we could be using stream processing to
compute these tallies. Recall that we
already have a user follower table which
is updated every time somebody receives
a new follower. We can build a change
data capture stream from this. This
workflow should be very reminiscent of
counting the number of likes on a
Facebook post. When a follower is added,
we handle updates in a downstream Kafka
consumer with a plus one and sync that
to a database. When a follower is
removed, we do the same with a minus
one. These updates can be batched to
ensure high throughput into the sync
database. Now, we can sync those changes
to a database and have an updated
follower count per user. We still
haven't accomplished our goal of having
a cache of popular users in memory. We
specifically want to be able to quickly
find out if a given user is popular. One
option here would be to use a look aside
cache. However, since that may not
contain the entire set of popular users,
we'd have to potentially check the
database to see if a user is popular or
not. In reality, the set of popular
users is so small that we can just
eagerly cache it. That way, we can tell
whether a user is popular or not by
checking if their ID is present in the
cache. To do so, we can employ change
data capture one more time. This time,
as users cross the popularity threshold
or even lose followers, we can add and
remove them from a Reddus cache.
Debeesium has a nice feature where you
can see the prior value of a particular
row. So our logic can simply check
whether the prior value is less than
10,000 and current value is greater than
or equal to 10,000. If so, we'll add the
user ID to the Reddis cache. In the
opposite case, we'll remove the user ID
from the Reddus cache. Recall that our
fanout consumers and newsfeed
application servers need to read this
cache each time a post is created or a
newsfeed is fetched. It's possible that
it could get overloaded. That being
said, because the set of popular users
is so small and fairly constant,
application servers can just cach it
locally for a few hours after a read. If
the value is slightly stale, it's not a
big deal. When our stream consumer
handles an incoming tweet, it figures
out all the followers of the tweet
author and then writes one row per
follower to the database. We may be
writing many hundreds or even thousands
of rows per post to our newsfeed
database. We want this to complete as
quickly as possible or else our post
handling throughput will be terrible. To
speed this part up, we can take
advantage of parallelism. Internally, we
want a database that can take a batch of
writes and internally mini batch them to
each shard as opposed to making a ton of
individual requests. We also want these
requests to execute in parallel as
opposed to sequentially. Cassandra, for
example, supports both logged and
unlogged batches where the difference
between them is that logged batches are
atomic rights across partitions. We
don't really care about atomicity here,
so we can use unlogged batches as a
performance optimization. If our right
fails on any of the shards, we'll just
retry it. These are item potent. We can
also significantly speed up fetching the
followers of a user. If a user has
multiple thousands of followers, getting
their IDs may not be instantaneous
because we need to get followers before
we can start writing to the newsfeed
database. This operation is in the
critical path. One way to speed this up
would be to cache the result of a query
to the database to fetch a user's
followers. However, most users aren't
actually tweeting all that often, so the
result would likely get stale before
they tweet again. Instead, we can
eagerly cache a user's followers. We can
stream updates from our user followers
table to the stream consumers
responsible for fan out. That way, when
posts come in, we don't have to make an
extra network call in order to figure
out who they should be sent to. If we
estimate that there are a billion users
with each having 100 followers on
average, and our user IDs are eight
bytes, it should take a bit less than a
terabyte to store this information. If
we decided that we wanted to cache it on
disk, this would be very feasible. We
can use something like Rox DB which is
an embedded key value store on disk to
store this mapping for us. In fact, this
is what stream processing frameworks
like Kafka streams or Flank will do for
us. Speaking of stream processing
frameworks, what if our stream consumer
were to go down? Then all of the cache
table state that it had built up over
time would also be lost. One option is
to just query the database again to get
user follower state. However, we also
need to subscribe to any incoming
changes after that. Ideally, since each
change data capture entry is associated
with some database transaction number,
we'd want to make a consistent snapshot
read from the database and then consume
change data capture from the transaction
after that. That being said, not every
database exposes the transaction number
that it used for snapshot reads. And
even if it did, it may be different than
the one used in the Dezium stream.
Perhaps we should let a stream
processing framework handle this for us.
Two good examples of these are Kafka
streams and flank. At a high level, our
goal here is to keep a copy of the user
following table on every single stream
processing node. Then we can handle one
Kafka partition of the post topic on
each consumer. Then we can handle one
each consumer. When a post comes in, we
join it with the cache table and make
our database rights. In Flink, the
abstraction of putting the same data on
each node can be accomplished by using
the broadcast syntax. In Kafka streams,
we use a global K table. For fault
tolerance, Flink performs checkpointing.
Kafka streams stores all of its internal
state in a write ahead log that is
itself persisted on Kafka. This key
value log gets compacted over time to
just keep the last value of each key. So
reading from it is basically the same as
reading a checkpoint. What if our user
followers table grew to become so big
that over time we couldn't keep it on a
single node? Then we'd have to partition
it across many different ones. The most
efficient way to model a problem like
this would be to perform a co-artition
join. In this example, we want to join
these two streams based on the user ID
of the user followers table and the
author ID of the incoming tweet. When we
have many consumers reading this data,
we don't want to have to shuffle data
around between them to match up
corresponding records. Instead, it would
be great if all messages from each
stream that could be joined with one
another were already handled by the same
consumer. In Kafka, we can accomplish
this if both topics are partitioned by
the join key and they both have the same
number of partitions. Then we just
assign the corresponding partitions to
the same consumer. As far as I can tell,
Flink doesn't do a very good job of
natively supporting colloccated joints.
When subscribing to two topics, it
doesn't seem to make any guarantees
about which partition is read on which
node. You can manually add a function to
ensure that each stream is keyed by the
join key within Flink. But this may add
an expensive shuffle step to your
process. Instead, the better approach is
probably to use Kafka streams which can
tell when two streams are partitioned
for a colloccated join. In the attach
code snippet, you can see that we create
a K table out of the incoming user
following relationships. We then join
the incoming stream of post data to
figure out all of the posters followers.
From there, we can make our batch writes
to the database. In the last piece of
this video, we'll evaluate if we really
need this whole complicated fan out
approach. In theory, it's really easy
for us to build a post database where
getting all recent posts from a single
user is very fast. The problem arises
when we begin to get all posts from
thousands of users at the same time.
This was actually a problem that
Facebook solved in their tow paper. They
were trying to fetch the news feed on
the fly so they wouldn't have to deal
with denormalized data and changing it
in many places at a time. But they
couldn't come up with any sort of
natural partitioning method to make sure
that every news feed query hit only a
single node.
In the end, they basically added a bunch
of caches to make the scatter gather
process as fast as humanly possible. In
such a system, you're bottlenecked by
tail latencies of the slowest nodes. One
solution that has been used in many
other systems is called request hedging.
In such an event, we can deal with nodes
that haven't responded for a bit by
issuing duplicate requests to their
replicas. Additionally, in the case of a
news feed, we can also return partial
results after some latency threshold.
Thank you all for stopping by. It's been
a pleasure. Hope you enjoyed the deep
dive format. Uh you guys are beauties
and I will see you in the next